i would like you on your devices
to pull up the last thing that we were
working on together
and you may remember last time i was
here in the room
what was it we were looking at what are
we looking at really a spreadsheet what
kind of spreadsheet were we looking at
fantastic profit and loss and we were
hoping not to have any
loss right but how much we were going to
charge for each of the items and
therefore how much profit we were going
to expect
and we generated that spreadsheet i'd
like you to pull it open now
get it open which is that everything you
were doing
in creating those spreadsheets was what
we call projecting
you were projecting right
uh what we were doing was we were
working out projected profits
much were we anticipating that we would
receive
and you guys did a lot of work
experimenting looking for different
prices
trying to maximize your profit margin
okay
but it was all just guesswork it was all
guesswork okay
now the athletics carnival has come and
gone and so we don't
need to do guesswork anymore
we have some actual figures so
i'm about to unveil for you what were
the actual numbers
from the athletics carnival and the
spreadsheet that really reflects reality
so
eyes up you ready i'm going to show it
to you
in all its glorious detail the
spreadsheet that was
put together okay now you can't see
everything there
i need to scroll down a little bit to
see what's going on but
this should look familiar it should look
familiar this has the same kind of
structure
that we had perhaps the columns are ever
so slightly different
but the important thing about this is
this is historical this is not projected
okay so let's start with the
commonalities you got all the items down
the left hand side here we were doing
this as well
right we're looking at cost price and
then we
we had some research with the women
looked at worse than condo et cetera
we thought about what prices would be
suitable and then this part here about
purchase
there was loads of guesswork involved
here we were trying everyone had
wildly different estimations on how many
donuts people would eat how many sausage
systems etc
we didn't know we did a projected
set of numbers right which is what you
guys did here's what actually happened
but what if it had happened differently
could we make we call this the bottom
line could we make the bottom line
any better than what it was okay so
the heading i'd like you to make and
wherever you're taking your notes on
this this is kind of like a
retrospective lesson
that we're learning i alluded to this
the last time i was in the room but i
needed this data to actually talk about
it
the heading i'd like you to make is
optimum
classy
now wherever you want to take notes
really on the stuff that you've been
learning from miss bleakly
under design all that kind of thing this
really is a design constraint
isn't it right money is a desire
constraint in fact
often money is the design constraint
okay so that's what we're working with
now in order to um help you understand
how to get an
optimum pricing point right like how
much should i charge for this
high enough that i'm making some profit
but low enough that lots of people will
actually come and buy
okay to illustrate this i'm actually
going to do an experiment with you all
right now
in some senses the questions are quite
self-explanatory but i want to help you
understand them a little more okay
so here's a pizza okay i thought long
and hard about what object i would
choose
okay now like i said do you remember i
asked you'll need to do this
individually
and that actually means not affecting
the opinion of those around you
really good about it i'm sorry here's a
pizza
think about it the four questions i'm
going to ask you are all to do
with price points okay now for the
purposes of
the analysis we're going to do in about
10 minutes when we're done here
when you put some numbers in here don't
don't put a dollar sign on there just
put just put a number it's okay if you
don't
you shouldn't have done it yet okay so
you might just put four
for four dollars okay the four questions
i'm asking you are
number one they sort of go in ascending
order what price for this pizza
would be so low that you think i think
something's wrong with this pizza okay
all right so so i would assume that this
number is quite low
to give you a bit of an analogy to this
i don't know if any of you guys have
been at the um
local shops when they do cheaper chicken
tuesday
you know what's in there okay cheap is
cheaper chicken monday just doesn't yeah
i don't know
anyway cheaper chicken tuesday okay and
the way it works is
pizzas have been out for a while uh
sorry pizzas chickens have been out for
a while right and they want to sell
these faster much like we were doing
with the sausage sizzles right
so they're additional i think what 12 is
the normal price
they'll make it eight and and if they've
been out since like 2 p.m
this is like at 6 or 7 p.m in the
evening now they won't just reduce it to
8
they'll reduce it to four bucks for a
whole chicken
okay now i don't know about you there's
a big enough
group here that we're all going to
differ but that number is so low that
i'm kind of like
i don't know if i want to buy this
chicken
yeah yeah they've been out there for
babies that's right
that's right so if they've been out
there for like hours and hours and hours
right it's like
i don't know i don't really want to get
food poisoning for this kind of thing
yeah yeah we bought a chicken once from
there we brought it home and opened it
though there's a fly in there yeah not
cool
no cool so so hopefully you understand
that at some point you're thinking no
this isn't just cheap and it's good
this is cheap and they're just trying to
get rid of it
so that ic would be a very low number
moving up
below the pizza you'll see what price
will be low enough
so you think hey i think this is a
bargain like this is actually good value
for this pizza
okay um i'm interested in buying it i
don't think it's so cheap that it's
dodgy
that number will be higher
as you go further as the prices rise
do you remember there were two things i
asked you do do you remember what they
were
shut up that was that was neither of
them what was the first thing
what was the first thing basically all
of you all of us
like two minutes ago can somebody help
him yeah thank you number one
individual number two number two someone
help us out
take it seriously thank you you are
doing either of those let's try harder
question three at some point and i would
uh suggest to you to stop thinking about
chickens and pizza for a second but
think about things like say this
now these are expensive
black rectangles right they are
deliberately expensive
so that we will view them as oh that's
really good quality
right they're making us pay a lot
because it's really worth it okay
so there's some price where it gets high
enough where you think oh this is
premium right which i assume will be
higher
last question there's a price where you
think
it's not just high as premium it's high
and it's ridiculous
i don't care how good this pizza is how
good this um this phone is
um has anyone been keeping up and knows
how much
a gold apple watch will cost anyone know
starts at 10 000. i'm like i don't care
how wonderfully golden that watch is i'm
not buying it that's ridiculous okay
now that's me maybe if i
went to the city and i went into like a
legal office someone who's earning
seven figures a year something like that
they might be like yeah
i could blow off ten thousand on that no
big deal so the point is and this is why
it's individual right
everyone's going to have different
numbers for these questions that's
actually really really important
so i'm going to give you about five
minutes now i actually want you to think
about it rather just give the first
response that comes to mind i want you
to think about it
four numbers and submit an answer okay
we're going to use these numbers so
think really hard about it okay
five minutes